well thank you very much and wonderful
have it from you Ron so thank
and also may I also thank the committee
on the broaden award for selecting me
I'm you know number as well I'm going to
become like in an oscar awards and break
down and cry and so but i really am
incredibly honored and grateful and and
you know everyone's been so kind
everyone seemed so efficient and it's
just such a great honor to be here at
all okay well this talk is about the
idea of an association of [ __ ] pneus
and music in Western culture generally
but also perhaps especially with in
American culture and the way that that
represents itself in the couple of
important films films that have always
been seen as key moments really in the
history of gay representation rope and
tea and sympathy two films that are
doing everything they can in a way
consciously to deny the fact that they
have anything at all to do with
homosexuality in fact when I showed rope
at in the 1977 season that Ron mentioned
in London several people I heard coming
out in wine earth was that shown he had
nothing to do with being homosexual so I
mean there was only one of the many
insulting things I overheard but so both
films in a way of consciously saying but
this is not really anything to do with
homosexuality don't imagine that it is
even though everyone knew that's what it
was but in in the course of that the
music has an interesting function
because the music is partly a way of in
fact declaring or not declaring but
suggesting cano ting a sense of a gay
presence in the film that somehow these
characters or the main characters are to
be seen as gay so on the one hand it
does seem the music is a way of as we're
bringing back again this and even that
dreaded thing gay sensibility which I
think we're not supposed to talk about
anymore but we used to talk about at one
time it's a way of bringing back gay
sensibility in films that are trying to
deny that they are anything to do with
come
sexuality but i think the film's at the
same time also suggests the the
vulnerability the precariousness of that
gay sensibility the way that it's it's
it's not really affirmed in the way the
gay liberation would of course be
calling for only 10 or 20 years later so
in a way it alls they also reveal the
precariousness of this expression of gay
sensibility but also the sense of
disturbance that there's something very
insecure and unstable about this
presence of gay sensibility that's
actually disturbing for the film as a
whole so what I'm suggesting is a
historical connection of [ __ ] pneus and
music this is represented in the film's
in a way that allows the film's in a way
to speak about homosexuality whilst
they're trying to deny it and but also
to suggest the precariousness and
troubling quality of that gay
sensibility okay so what I'm going to
talk about assumes have managed to go to
that slide immediately we can see
something a little bit more about the
idea of music and the feminine and then
say something even shorter about gay men
and the feminine before turning to talk
about the way rope and tea and sympathy
deal with those okay so first of all to
deal with the question of music and the
feminine and I think it's true to say
that there is a very long association in
relation and it's important to put in
this qualification in relation to white
what and what we now call classical
music so it's I'm very much I talk about
music I'm talking about what white
traditions of music and there's a whole
interesting I think history to be
written about the sense often within the
white imagination of the virility of
black music and or indeed of certain
kinds of folk amuse white folk music as
well and the need for that virility to
kind of rescue the endemic quality of
white classical music so there's a whole
thing to be said there about the racial
in 30 commerce hate when people do that
actually but anyway about about the
about the ethylene character or the
color in one might
of different kinds of music but that
bracket that out because the film's I'm
dealing with are very much dealing with
music with in white classical music
tradition and there's a long tradition
of thinking about that music as in some
sense feminine something that women like
something that's not quite masculine and
of that being a certain kind of source
of anxiety which must be damped down put
in its place and dealt with and one way
of registering that is through the
phrase that was used a great deal
particularly in American cinema but of
course beyond the cinema of this this
being long hair music now it referred to
of course that the men involved in this
music had long hair but because we know
that long hair by the certain in the
20th century long hair connotes the
feminine men have short hair women have
long hair so long hair music the very
term does suggest something about that
they're kind of it that somehow that
anna and sort of manly and unease about
the gender of white classical music and
the term was actually specifically used
by door sherry in the negotiations
around the making of tea and sympathy
when he said oh well this he said
something like this of course the
character isn't really homosexual they
all were saying that it's just that he
likes long hair music and that was it
that's a bit iffy and he's got to be
rescued even from that and this is
quoted in various places but I'm happy
to quote it from the late George custom
a great scholar who died very suddenly
about think now about even as much as
ten years ago but a great loss and
pleased to be just referencing his essay
on the making of tea and sympathy so
long that that term comes in the film
and it's about you find it very widely
used particularly in American culture in
the 20th century as a kind of unease
about classical music but this goes back
much further into the 19th century and a
whole series of debates about the
gendered quality of music and
particularly a famous essay by Robert
Schumann which is about the c major
symphony of
uber in which he compares the symphony
which he does greatly admire but he
compares Schubert unfavorably in the end
with Beethoven he's kind of uneasy with
Schubert there's something kind of wishy
and sentimental and emotional about
Schubert and what what's the best thing
is them is the virility and the
masculinity of Beethoven and this has
been of great interest to musicologists
in the last 20 years or so this is
discovering of these whole debates about
the gendered quality of classical music
and a feeling that there's always a
danger that classical music is somehow
going to become too feminine be
overwhelmed by its femininity and not
have the masculine virility of Beethoven
and the one of the first people to
really talk about this was Susan
McCleary and a groundbreaking sa button
there's also a whole book on Schubert by
Lawrence Kramer and there are two
aspects that McCleary are particularly
talks about one is simply the idea of
music being about emotions and the way
that the Romantic movement introduced
this emphasis upon being emotional and
that that and that at the same time was
also seen as the province of women it
was also seen as being about the body
and there was a whole discourse in a way
in which men should master and even
transcend the body whereas women are
sort of condemned to being live living
entirely in the body so there's a whole
way in which a general emotionality is
associated with music in these
discourses about classical music and
with femininity but particularly
importantly I think is a sense of moat
emotional particularly you get to the
late 19th century of emotional
instability that it's not just that they
have these passionate emotions is that's
prepped okay it's these vague emotions
these emotions aren't quite resolve what
emotions are they they're falling apart
they're at their fragmentary that
they're confusing they're ambiguous it's
that whole exploration of that area of
music which is what you get is that as
the 19th century proceeds and into the
20th century that suggests emotional
instability
and there's an interesting passage which
some whose significance you'll see in a
moment in my Clarice discussion of
Schubert where she's talking about
actually his eighth symphony but she
puts forward the argument that that the
whole organization does not enact the
more standard model in which our self
strives to define identity through
consolidation of ego boundaries that's
as it were the masculine a goal of
classical music the Beethoven ideal in a
Beethoven world that would seem
vulnerable would be a sort of identity
the tonal identity would not be safely
anchored that sense of what what tote
what harmony are we in now where which
key are we in now it keeps shifting that
would be a source of anxiety she
suggests in sort of the Beethoven the
masculine music whereas in the feminine
music it's all its kind of it's
acceptable as part of the kind of just
the range of kinds of emotions that can
be had down big you ities the subtleties
and so on and she suggests that there's
often a need to introduce to kind of
clamp down on in Beethoven on those
unstable emotions which are nonetheless
and perhaps more accepted within a
composer like Schubert now because a lot
of the interest in this comes from the
fact that Schubert may well himself have
been game he's still much debate about
it but there is a lot of it this
certainly sprang from an interest in an
assumption that he was not as it were
gender normative I think you've even
look at the pictures I think I've put
them let me just go back to the pictures
that you've got here this kind of the
man with his pencil in his hand looking
very firm and stone and then we have
Schubert's all sort of lying back so
don't even even even in the depiction
there you get that Center and people
have been very interested in that and
then also in some evidence to suggest
that Schubert was perhaps himself gay so
so the other thing just to say then is
about gaming at eight men and femininity
because and I almost don't need to say
more than that is except to say that
that has been for at least 200 years you
know
an assumption that somehow if men are
not real men then they may be something
worse ie they may be queers and then
anxiety and in fact the the production
code never quite named homosexuality and
production code in New in Hollywood
everything was conveyed for what we
mustn't have men being effeminate
because you know this may suggest
perverse sexuality where we all know
what perverse sexuality they had in mind
so what I'm putting together here is a
long tradition of anyway associating
music and certain kinds of music and
this kind of unresolved emotionally
ambiguous music putting that together
with femininity and then also putting
that together with the association of
gay men with femininity but just one
other thing which is almost a bit of
more like gossip but but people who in
America thought Oh classical music is
that all a bit iffy on the sort of you
know aren't they all a bit so queer
actually in a way they had a reason to
think that just think of some of the
most famous composers in America in
American history and you do an apart
from Charles Ives you've got practically
all them sort of major figures you've
also got people haven't put there like
Virgil Thomson and Mark Blitzstein and
of course the lyricist lorenz hart so
it's it there's a way in which perhaps
people had a reason to think there might
be a problem there might be a problem of
sis eNOS in relation to music now what I
want to do now then is to think about
that in relation to the two films listed
in the title so first of all rope made
in 1948 rope is based upon the famous
murder by Leopold and low of a young boy
in 1928 and there is some actually
discussion of me and it's always
generally assumed that they were gay but
there's some suggestion that perhaps
only one of them was and the other was
manipulating that or whatever but still
it the basic wyd assumption has always
been that they are gay and it's been a
source of constant fascination so there
is for instance the original play by
Patrick Hamilton which is what the film
is based on which was made in mrs.
Webster's 1929 written in 1929 there is
a film that confirmed compulsion made in
59 which was actually partly a polemic
against capital punishment there is the
film swoon which a previous Brandner
award winner Ruby rich was one of the
films that she named as part of this new
movement called known as now as new
queer cinema and there was recently also
a musical but actually rather good
musical called thrill me made in 2003 so
we have a situation of a story that's
very widely assumed to be gay both in
the news coverage of the time but also
in every version made since and yet
which in the film there's certainly no
direct mention of that and you have to
kind of read between the lines and so on
in the film the two killers become
Phillip and Brandon and Phillip and
Brandon are in fact played by Farley
Granger and John doll both of whom were
gay and the script was by Arthur
Laurents who during the year or so that
rope was being prepared was in fact
having an affair with farley granger so
the quite a lot of people is involved in
it who in some way or other were gay and
yet still the idea of the was that the
music that the film should not should be
thought to be not really gay but
interestingly then is the use of music
now there is no background music at all
the music is music that's being played
in the scene of the film and the whole
film takes place at a party immediately
after the killing of a young man by that
by Phillip and Brandon and and they've
put they have put the body in a chest
and they're now Brett sort of you know
sort of rather defiantly having this
party around the body in the chest so
the only music it's their only two
sources of music and one is a piece of
music by constance francis and on
translate french francis poulenc and
francis poulenc is was a well known to
be gay composer and apart from that
picture i just thought it was nice to
see this picture of him with jean
cocteau and one of the most i suppose
declared outs of gay people
20th century internal energy French
history the piece of music that is
involved is a piece of meat recalled
movement perpetual perpetual movement
and I want to begin I want to just now
then play you and just find the right
thing the this version in the in fact in
the version as played by pooling himself
ok so that's it goes on a bit and it's
one to pull it out play it again but
this time I'm going to put up as well an
analysis of it you know article by Scott
Pauline find it
I think what's interesting about this
analysis is the echoes of the Susan
McCleary account of the analysis for
Schubert the sense this is a piece of
music that keeps shifting key keep
shifting direction despite being
perpetual move despite rolling along
fluidly rolling along it's still
nonetheless very unresolved very
ambiguous ironic charming and yet
somehow I'm not quite in a definite key
in the way that might be reporting it
might be thought to be a sort of proper
in a piece of music okay and there's
also another interesting part from the
artic what you've just seen the Scot
Pauline article there's also another
interesting article by gary thomas about
the use of this piece of music in this
film okay so now i want to then now look
at and the use of the music in the film
itself and then I'll take first of all
the first time we hear it the murders
been committed the body is in by
strangling and the body is hidden in the
chest and the party has begun and the
friend called mrs. Atwater claims to be
able to read read palms and this is the
sequence that begins with her reading
palms and I think perhaps I don't need
to say anything more than that I'll make
some comments on it afterwards so let's
have a look at this sequence may I see
are you don't remember the out of your
birth manager no good finger drum itt
what about the color lip the Farley
Granger is of course appeared then we'll
bring you great favor well
very fortunate man I'm on and the grand
oak what your collections of the street
oh yes of course even today oh how
lovely your wife sends her love David
wasn't there no he'll probably be here
in a minute though
your touch is improved Phillip Robert
okay to go back to the PowerPoint for a
moment well there are two things that I
particular want emphasize of course
there is the irony the irony is that
what she's saying of course you are
going to be famous for your hands and of
course he's going to be famous because
his hands were used to strangle someone
but she thinks well she means he's going
to be famous for playing so it's
interesting that the the the jermichael
the weapons of murder are also the means
of producing this pretty little game
piece of music so we've got the kind of
a sense of which that there's a link
almost between the camera anxiety that
Phillip feels because he's a much more
anxious about the whole thing that his
anxiety is being linked at the same time
to his being able to play the piano but
unless he goes down and plays it
actually but slightly slower than the
beach version I played you which was
pulling himself but he plays it slower
but still absolutely confidently and so
on and then enter Rupert who is the
mentor of the characters and the moment
Rupert comes in he stops the plane so
Rupert who in the play is a much more
himself seems to be a gay character here
he represents absolutely the kind of
straight stopping of this charming
little tune being played so whereas you
notes and so what we've got so far is
the music's function is to kind of be an
expression and into a completely in
direct expression of an amp of a tonally
ambiguous but charming and ironic piece
of music which is suddenly brought to an
end by the arrival of the very much or
thought that male authority figure okay
well I move on then to a second extract
and this is a little bit later and it
starts with a conversation between the
woman who is some helping them put out
the meal mrs. Wilson and she is
discussing with Rupert that james
stewart character the fact that the two
boys seem to be very much on edge and so
on and i've started it here because
there's another piece of music that is
actually being used and this is piece of
music but I played it's actually a song
called four-leaf clover which is kind of
the absolute most kind of oh isn't life
wonderful I'm looking over a four-leaf
clover it's absolutely kind of no
problems everything's wonderful and so
on but played by this rather strange
quartet or 30 and we're put in the extra
man this strange trio of men in this
strange harmony then we see this very
rather odd little burbling little sort
of electric organ music that you hear in
the background so although the music in
one way is it absolutely represents
normality it's cheerful its associated
particularly with the heterosexual
couple that's already beginning to form
within the film and it's being put on
deliberately in order to foster their
relationship nonetheless there's also
something kind of odd about it and if it
was quite good to have that in the
background but then we moved to simplify
my own notes yeah we then moved to a
sequence between once again Philip and
the character of Rupert and at one point
I just need to mention explain one thing
before it's suggesting things are
interesting about this sequence is that
there was reference to strangling a
chicken earlier in the film we've been
told about the fact that Philip was
supposed to strangle a chicken at
brandons mother's house and he made a
mess of it he wasn't really up to
strangling a chicken and obviously it's
a coded way of saying Phillips a bit of
a loose cannon here he's not reliable
he's not even all that good it's killing
people not even like good at strangling
chickens so we have heard this remark
you know it's kind of it's just it was
surprised it would surprise you to hear
it in the film if you didn't know why it
was being mentioned however I think
what's interesting about this sequence
is first of all you've got this sense of
this normal music that's then being
replaced by this one I'm suggesting is
this sort of game music in the pulang
but also most interestingly is the way
the music itself get stopped and then
starts again it gets broken up it the
playing loses it
way so this charming piece of music that
is itself somewhat understand and in
emotional terms not that definite
becomes more broken up more challenged
as Rupert the carriage of Rupert
effectively challenges it including
including calling it that little to you
like that little tune don't you this
rather the patronizing way he talks
about the music so there's almost like a
battle going on between the get the
charming ironic gay voice of the music
and the inquiring rationalistic
patriarchal voice of the Rupert
character and that's then reinforced a
certain point when Rupert puts on a
metronome and so we have the contrast
between the metronome which is absolute
regular movement absolute insistence
like March rhythm running counter to the
movement perpetual of the of the pool
ank that group that Phillip is trying to
play and keeps losing his way with it
and I think what's really interesting
about that is not only a contrast of the
regular they are both in fact perpetual
movement but one is a notion of
perpetual movement as much more
industrial much more based upon an
imposed order fitting into a certain
kind of mathematical definiteness
whereas the perpetual movement of the
pulang relates much more actually two
thoughts thinking about time and tempo
in the period in France where yes it's
perpetual but it's also it keeps
changing speed keep chasing rhythm but
it's much more broken up in now but even
the but the piece of music itself is a
fluid sense of perpetual motion as
opposed to an industrial one so what
we've got set here against is the the
metronome imposing one kind of rhythm
and one kind of time and the music
trying to be a different kind of time
but then constantly breaking down in the
face of this patriarchal assault so
let's some look at that extract
why did you serve from here I had
everything laid out she's still harping
on a table and how awkward it is to
serve from this but it's really much
more convenient you know because this
way people don't have to go all the way
into the dining room to get their food
come all the way back here to eat hmm
seems to me they've gone all the way in
there now for their dessert and coffee
mrs. Wilson please serve the guests
don't
I'm in quite an embarrassing position
how do you mean well I seem to be the
only one having a good time you and mrs.
Atwater what's going on to them would
you mind turning that off
when I compare of light in my eyes
the siren is you have the way on the
film and that's that the thing I get
into the sound the evil don't out your
questions are coming to get the boy cure
it did us any that sarin much really I
well what was it I asked you what is
going on here
a party yes but a rather peculiar party
what's all about her what's one more
about that's the plain crime and
punishment Rupert you want to know
something come out with that otherwise
on our temper temper now don't stop I'd
like a drink wait I'll get it for you I
keep playing what would you like scotch
well Brandi very fond of Evan Turner you
know Phillip I wish I could come
straight out with what I want to know
unfortunately I don't know anything
merrily suspect I said that I heard you
that's all right thank you you use it
sometimes I thought only beginner said I
must say all right i'll ask you what do
you suspect
I forgot where's David thought I don't
know what Brandon knows does it does
make that I know oh come I don't what to
ask brandon i have but he's too busy
maneuvering the other two points in the
triangle what for Phillip just what is
Brandon trying to do with Janet and
Canada where you like about thick man
what it what I'm what am I so far off
the track there's nothing going on at
all loop it
more than usually allergic to the truth
tonight Phillip that's the second time a
plethora thanks when was the first you
said you'd never strike with chicken
you're confused random dreamt that up
the sake of the very unfunny joke no he
didn't know he didn't tell and if you'll
think back very carefully you realize
that I know he did a year ago super farm
forever one morning I saw you display
your handiwork you're quite a good
chicken the strangler as I could call
well I'd I just met the Brandon story
wasn't true I didn't mean ahead and kill
any chicken that's what you're sad well
I I didn't think was a suitable taunting
of conversation while you're eating you
could have said that alright I didn't
we're not eating now Phillip what you
lied him before because I don't like to
talk about about what strangling play
with I think want you to happen very
much it's extremely generous of you
Brandon I ok so what I've been
transferred to event at the end of the
film they are of course found out by
Rupert and the police are on their way
and we have an attempt to pick out the
tune but it's completely drowned by for
the first time this huge Orchestra
coming in and affirming that indeed this
pretty little tune is not going to be
allowed to be the tune that that
survives right through at the end of the
film so I mean try and suggest in this K
in the case of this film is that the
Magistra firm acting is that this piece
of music which has in many ways which is
in which it which belongs to a whole
tradition of a piece of music that's
tonally ambiguous and relates to a sense
of emotional uncertainty but an ease
with emotional uncertainty which relates
to an idea also of charm and irony all
of that is being used in the film partly
as a ways away for Phillip to affirm
himself and to keep keep calm in the
face of this all terrible thing that
they've done but it's in competition
with this kind of voice of authority
coming from james stewart and in the
it's defeated by both musically but also
by the actions of the james stewart
character so suggesting the disturbance
and the vulnerability of this kind of
music well I want to turn from that then
to tea and sympathy which was made in
1956 and tin sympathy was based on a
play that was originally produced in
1953 you see also see here the pulp pulp
fiction version I say that it actually
is the play script inside but it was it
was resold at the time of the making of
the film as if you were going to get a
novel but it's actually the play inside
so it was actually a very well-known
property and the play is again pretty
clearly about homosexuality and in fact
in during the negotiations alya Kazan
who had directed the original production
and was in negotiation about MGM making
the film version it was absolutely
unequivocal the whole thing is about
homosexuality but in the course of a
long long negotiations which have been
looked at in both these things I've put
up here that the homosexuality was
increasingly denied not talked about
took thought about merely in terms of
someone who's missing his mother someone
who likes long hair music someone who
likes folk music as I can complete an
attempt to completely utterly go against
the idea that the whole thing is about
homosexuality though that's what
everyone knew was the case now in a very
interesting article by David gerstner he
suggests that that repression of any
explicit reference to homosexuality is
as it were comes back in the form of the
taste of the film that the film
particularly the visual taste of the
film is it is it is it is a sort of good
taste in a certain kind of interior
decoration kind of tradition of gay men
and not not of course by no and not by
coincidence the director of the film is
Vincente Minnelli of course who is in
way a fascinating case because he is
kind of was here wasn't he well probably
yes but we weren't supposed to know it
so he's almost he's in the same neck of
the woods
these films themselves but ger sinners
argument I think is very interesting in
suggesting that the as it were the
gayness is as it were put on to the
excessive good taste and and beautiful
careful decoration and clothing and
flowers and so on that that run
throughout the whole film now what I
want to suggest is that taking on going
on from david Gerson's argument is that
you could say the same thing about the
music as well that the music is again
where we are going to get some of this
concern with gay sensibility now the
music is based upon a piece of music by
maurice ravel and this is called pavan
for a dead in Infanta written in 1899
Ravel again is an interesting figure
much less very much a dandy and much
much speculation about his sexuality
certainly he wasn't in any conventional
sense heterosexual though he was much
less known to be think of himself as gay
than a poulenc that we dealt with before
but the whole question of his his scared
entertain his gay association has been
wonderfully written about by lloyd white
sullen in this article Ravel's way in a
collection that he and Sophie fuller put
together now not only do i wants to not
only then does it come with certain
connotations of historically you know
that in a way Ravel is part of this kind
of [ __ ] chromatically ambiguous
probably homosexual musical culture but
interestingly and I only discovered this
on the train between Boston and New
Haven yesterday it was dedicated to
winnaretta singer and winner at a singer
married and her second marriage was to
the very much older pass the Pauline yak
who was gay and a composer so there's
quite interesting sort of background
associations which may or may not of
course have been fully known but it
comes out of a certain kind of world now
so what I want to do now is to play you
first of all the pavane
for a dead in Fanta just to give you a
familiarity then I'm going to put the
play the opening of the film and
although that of course it isn't exactly
the same tune but the long arching over
opening melodic phrase and then the
harmonics are very close to each other
though you do also get this or MGM big
Orchestra harmonics as well in the case
of the opening sequence of tea and
sympathy anyway let's just listen to the
Ravel
okay and now we'll look at the and
listen to the opening of tea and
sympathy
you
okay so that forms the basis of the
music background the background music in
the film and it's used on and off
throughout the film and i want to show
you this two sequences one is this first
is that a sequence near the beginning
when the main character Tom goes to back
to his old school reunion and the whole
film is a flashback to him remembering
how he was teased because he was a [ __ ]
boy because he was at night long haired
music and the stories of well-known so
the story is of him being befriended by
the wife of the house master where he
lives and she in order to rescue him
from his gender uncertainty and no doubt
worse has has sex with him and that
we're supposed to think has cured him
it's in the film with really are
supposed to think that in the play it's
fairly clear that it was very kind of
her but it didn't really take but anyway
this is this it's sequence and what's
interesting about this sequence I think
is that we start with again with this
kind of rebellion piece of music which
is the main music of the film and it's
very much sorry let me just find my own
notes to remind myself what I'm supposed
to be saying it's very much we get we
get we get that both the beginning of
the sequence and in towards the end of
the sequence so if this is the kind of
slightly melancholy slightly emotionally
insecure and motion the uncertain kind
of emotion that we're getting at the
time but then that gives way to music
that is the college song so again we've
got like a contest between the gay
sensibility music if you like and the
straight college song music and then
towards the end we also hear another
piece of music and this is actually the
song plays Yiadom or the the joys of
love which is was written in 1780 so
it's a very old song but I think what's
interesting about it is that it was made
it was used in the film the heiress made
in 1949 which one might say is a
somewhat overdetermined gay text even
though the director was William
who is battling peps not a particularly
k director about nonetheless based on a
text by Henry James music by Aaron
Copland starring Montgomery Clift and
also Miriam Hopkins so really quite a
lot of gay sensibility going into this
so at the end of the film at the end of
the sequence we also get that piece of
music now what's interesting about that
piece of music is not only not so much
that can of gossipy links with the
heiress but this again is a song of
sensibility front rambha right in the
Romantic era it's a make it's a
melancholy song but also it has because
it's played on the guitar it has the
character of a folk song and there's a
very curious moment in the film when the
father of the boy tom who is the main
character Tom's father says it's so
embarrassing to have a son who tells you
what he wants to be when he grows up and
you think he's going to say the interior
decorator and a hairdresser or something
he wants to be a folk singer so there
seems to have been some connotation of
folk singing being not quite calm UFO at
the time so we've got in this sequence
the kind of a contest of different kinds
of music all of which are around the
kind of question of placing Tom in
relation to a kind of normative idea of
gender and sexuality so let's have a
look at this
oh I don't think they're in well I used
to live here 10 years ago do you think
they'd mind if I went in no of course
not
and one of these interesting is that if
you listen towards the end of hearing
this college song it begins to take on
in fact as a Ravel harmonies and
instrumentation
you
choice
our bra
long
grief of
Anders
okay so um in the course of the film is
to move on to yep so I'm just in the
course of the film not only is he
taunted he also tries to have sex with a
local prostitute but then finds the
whole thing disgusting and runs out and
then finally is seduced by the Deborah
car character now music continues to be
important and not only music in this the
association of this Ravel type music it
with a Tom story but also as actually
subject matter in the film there's very
famous scene you see at the top here in
the music room and this is famous it's
used in the film of the celluloid closet
for instance it's a scene in which this
man who's a friend of Tom's tries to
show him how to walk like a man it's
sort of favor it's a really it's a
wonderfully funny scene trying to
believe trouble is you walk you walk in
the springy way and you need to walk
like this so that's why it's a famous
scene but it is in fact in the music
room and we have the reassuring possibly
bust of Beethoven in the middle there
but also I think very interesting is the
whole idea of listening to music and
it's bad enough to like classical music
but then to sit passively listening to
it and there's a whole history of the
passivity of response to music that's
also present and also often playing from
melancholy romantic music so this this
is an important scene in the film but
also important is a moment in which the
housemaster who's a very match show type
says to Tom don't you think when I was a
young man I too would sit for hours in
my weeping in my room listening to music
but I repressed it I became a real man
so that association of weeping with a
effeminacy with music is again important
theme in the film and at the end of the
film when Tom we see Tom going back and
knocking on the door of the house master
was now his wife has left him and what
do we see we see him sitting listening
to music rather affirming something
that's been suggested throughout the
film that of course the house master
himself had the same problems as did Tom
now these problems are compensated for
by what now I suppose looks like nothing
but doesn't doesn't really look like
it's hiding its gayness at all but these
sequences are meant to show that in the
the house masters kind of affirmation of
his masculinity well obviously we may
now tend to read that as being so
excessively affirmed as to suggest that
the he too has the same kinds of erotic
feelings as Tom so at the end of the
film Tom opens a letter that's been left
for him from Deborah car and I want to
know just play you this sequence to end
with because in this sequence she talked
about the fact that you know she split
up from her husband and that the book at
the book that Tom road is not quite
right but i think what interest is
what's interesting is that the beginning
of this when he you hear her voice and
the music here is completely unknown
adik you don't know where it doesn't
know where it's going it's it's
completely it's within it tonally
actually it is quite Ravel but
nonetheless it doesn't have any of the
melodic sense then at a certain point
the letter refers to the husband and the
film having moved in on a camera
movement cuts to a shot of the husband
who is in the study just off the garden
here and then the camera moves back and
as the camera moves back the ravel theme
comes in which seems to be very clearly
linking the housekeeper and Tom as being
part really of the same emotionally
unstable sensibility but with a sense
perhaps we may like to feel any way that
the repression all it's all that's done
is left in weeping by the gramophone for
that for the housemother the
a cutting of the word the man who runs
the house where Tom live at whereas
perhaps tom is much more reconciled
we're meant to thinking we in fact we're
told he's married and so on but I think
we can actually see it as much more
someone who is comfortable with his gaze
and civility so let's I mean again if we
want to see it that way so let's have a
look at this last sequence from the film
Tom dear they have just read your book
your novel about your days in school
about us it is a lovely book tinder and
romantic and touching and in it I come
out rather like a saint but Tom that
isn't the whole picture or even the true
picture you have romanticized the wrong
we did and not looked at it clearly at
the end of the story you say that the
husband was far better off without his
wife and the wife went on to her own
happy life you're quite wrong tom as
you'll know I couldn't go back to bail
after that afternoon with you and
pretend that nothing
happened and my not going back ruined
his life
16 I find that I sacrificed bill and our
marriage he thought he knew what he
wanted to be left alone just as you
thought you knew what you wanted to kill
yourself both of you in a sense were
crying out to be saved from what you
thought you wanted I answered your cry
he was the easier one to answer
okay so what I've been trying to argue
is that in both these films men trying
to argue something about the way in
which this music in a way represents
something about the conditions of
expressivity in a period in which you
can't be openly and direct about lesbian
or gay identity and it both suggests the
richness of the possibilities of
indirection the kind of use of irony the
use of emotional exploration and
uncertainty the sense of a lucid pneus
so they both suggests the rich
possibilities of this condition of
cultural production so in the kind of
half open closet it also suggests the
vulnerability of this form of expression
the way it can actually be squashed down
much more clearly in rope than in tea
and sympathy we're in a way it does
survive or be it very tenuous Lee but it
also suggests that perhaps there was
something quite disturbing I don't know
that I hate these for cleansing for
transgressive pneus and some very strong
way but there was just something
disorienting destabilizing about this
emotionally uncertain ambiguous ironic
music that actually produced a felt need
to repress it so we both have the
richness of the tradition its
vulnerability but also its potential for
disturbance and this seems to me an
interesting I hope example of the
aesthetics of cultural queer culture of
russian gay culture production under the
condition of the closet thank you very
much
you